في بحث 12 شهر 6 اللي فات في واحده من
المجلات العلميه وبعضها على طول بكذا شهر
نزل مقال في موقع ذا جورديان الاتنين
بياكدوا نفس الخبر الخبر ان الكوره دي
لقوها في حليب ام بترضع
طيب حصلت ازاي وايه هي الكوره دي وازاي
اصلا حاجه بالحجم ده توصل لحليب الام عشان
نجاوب على الاسئله دي محتاجين نرجع شويه
ورا بالزمن فتعالوا معي نبدا الحكايه من
الاول
في ليله الكريسماس 1894 جعالم اسمه
ارهينيوس وبدل ما ياكل كيك ويحتفل مع
اصحابه قرر انه يعمل اول كلايمه موديل او
اول نموذج للمناخ في التاريخ عشان يقدر
يحسب من خلاله نسبه انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون او السي اوتو واللي هو يعتبر من
اهم الغازات الدفيئه اللي بتحبس الحراره
جوه الارض وبتادي للاحتباس الحراري
والحقيقه دي كانت اول خطه
ارهينيوس في الوقت ده كان متخيل ان احنا
قدامنا سنين كتير قوي عشان اصلا نوصل
لنسبه انبعتات خطيره بس السيربرايز اللي
عملناه في اخر 30 الف سنه وصلنا له بس في
اخر 30 سنه
بعدها بكذا سنه بدا العالم يدرك خطوره
اللي بيحصل وقالوا بقى لا خلاص احنا كده
محتاجين نتجمع ونعمل قعده جديه وفي 1992
فريود جينير وعاصمه البرازيل حصل واحد من
اول المؤتمرات المناخيه اسمه
اللي كانوا عايزين يناقشوا فيه مجموعه
حلول للمشكلات اللي بتحصل للارض فضل يحصل
بعدها مجموعه مؤتمرات ونقاشات عالميه لحد
كوب 20 اللي حصل في باريس 2015
واللي تم فيه واحده من اهم اتفاقيات
المناخ اسمها
او اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ الاتفاقيه دي كان
بتنص على مجموعه وعود والزامات وتعويضات
على الدول الكبيره والمسؤوله قصاد العالم
بشكل كبير في ازمه التلوث
في الوقت ده كمان الافلام بدات تدرك خطوره
اللي بيحصل يعني مثلا في 2009 نزل الفيلم
اللي كان قلق كل العالم تقريبا فيلم او
2012 مش عارفه لو انتم فاكرينه الفيلم ده
من كتر ما الناس كانت مرعوبه منه كانوا
بيسموه فيلم يوم القيامه اللي هو خلاص كده
برضو فضل يعني الافلام دي كتير جدا حتى
اغلب الافلام في الوقت ده كان ليها فيما
موحده فيه نهايه العالم وازاي ان كل حاجه
بتمشي بسرعه جدا
لنهايتها لسته الافلام المشابهه واللي
اتكلمت في قضيه نهايه يعني نهايه العالم
دي لسه لا تنتهي لحد اخر فيلم نزل في 2021
فيلم don't lock up
لو كانوا بيبصوا كلهم فوق ده مش عارفه لو
انتم عارفينه ده برضو كان بيتكلم عن نفس
الفكره ولكنه حاول يبعد شويه عن هاجس
نهايه العالم بقى والهيستيريا دي وحاول
يركز اكتر في ضروره سرعه التحرك لانقاذ
الارض دلوقتي بعد 30 سنه من اول مؤتمر
اتعمل فيريو جينيرو نقدر نقول ان السوشيال
ميديا هي كمان بقى لها دور مهم وفعال في
التوعيه بازمه المناخ ويمكن كمان يكون
اكبر واهم من دور المؤتمرات العالميه
وبالارقام منصات السوشيال ميديا اللي
المهتمه بامور المناخ عالميا اصلا بقى لها
خلاص جمهورها اللي بيتابعها وفي 2020
منصات السوشيال ميديا المستدامه او
السستاني بالسوشيال ميديا اللي هي بتستخدم
الطاقه المتجدده او حتى بتدعم الاستهلاك
المستدام جذبت اكثر من ثلاثه ونصف مليار
مستخدم عالميا مليار مش مليون متخيلين
في دراسه اتعملت في 2014 بتقول ان 55% من
الناس اللي بتحب تشتري حاجات اون لاين او
المستهلكين اون لاين عندهم ميل ان هم
يدفعوا اكتر قصاد منتجات او خدمات بتدعم
البيئه ده غير ان في 90% من الناس اللي
بتحب تعمل شوبينج اون لاين عندهم استعداد
ان هم يغيروا من شركه لشركه بس لان هم
لقوا الشركه دي بتدعم قضايا بتهم البيئه
والمجتمع النسب دي وغيرها كتير كانت فرصه
للشركات والمؤسسات ان هي بقى تبدا تلتفت
ازاي ممكن يدعموا البيئه اصلا من خلال
المنتجات اللي بيطلعوها
بس الحقيقه دي كمان فرصه لناس تانيه ان هم
يعملوا حاجه اسمها
بالبلدي كده معناها انه احنا هنضحك عليكم
باسم البيئه ودعم الارض والكلام ده عشان
نبيع اكتر يعني مثلا
عمركم شفتم منتجات مكتوب عليها كلام رنان
جدا زي ريو زبل
من غير ما يوضح لك اصلا على المنتج ده هو
ايه هنا بالظبط لصديق للبيئه ايه هنا
بالظبط اللي صفتين البدله
ساعات برضو تلاقيهم بيتلووا على الحقايق
عشان يبهروك كمستخدم فمثلا تلاقيه بيصور
لك المنتج في الحياه البريه والطبيعه فانت
بقى تشتري خلاص ان المنتج ده طبيعي تمام
ما فيش مشكله بس هو ممكن ما يبقاش طبيعي
عادي جدا
طيب لو اعتبرنا ان دي مجرد يعني ماركه
وحيل تسويقيه وما فيش منها مشكله اخلاقيه
قوي بس ليه بيتمرر لنا حيل شبهها من منصات
ومؤسسات المفروض اهتمامها الاساسي اصلا هو
البيئه وبدل ما بيتحروا الدقه ويدونا
الابديتس الجديده في موضوع المناخ بيقدموا
لنا معلومات مش دقيقه يعني مثلا انا لحد
وقت قصير فات
كنت متخيله ان الكوبايه الورق اللي قدامكم
دي كلنا حاسين ان احنا ننقذ بها السلاحف
والله هي كمان طلعت مضره للبيئه
ليه لان هي ملفوفه بطبق رفيعه جدا من
البلاستيك ده غير اصلا الكعب الغطا اللي
بيبقى عليها وبالتالي اصلا بتاع التحلل
الكوبايه الورق بتبقى معقده جدا لان احنا
بنحتاج نفصل الطبقه الرفيعه من البلاستيك
عشان تروح لاعاده التدوير
والورق يروح للتحلل
طيب ليه ما فيش تركيز في السوشيال ميديا
والاعلام على غاز الميثان ودوره في ازمه
المناخ وكل التركيز مصبوب على السي او تو
واثر ثاني اكسيد الكربون
يعني مثلا
تخيلوا معي قبل ما اقول لكم مثلا تخيلوا
معي ان غاز الميثان قادر على رفع درجه
حراره الارض في العشر سنين جايين قد اللي
عمله
ومع ذلك انا عرفت عنه بالصدفه البحته خالص
بعمل سكرار على تويتر عادي ولقيت خبر
بيقول ان نيوزلانكا بتفكر ان هي تفرد
ضرايب على الابقار
فانا اللي هو ابقار ايه يا جماعه اللي
هتفرضوا عليها ضرايب يعني عملت ايه
ودي كانت اول مره اكتشف فيها انه غازات
الابقار من اهم مصادر غازات الميثان ولها
مصادر تانيه كتير زي الحقول اللي بيتغمر
بيها زي الميه اللي بيتغمر بها حقول الرز
والتسريبات بتاعه انابيب الغاز الطبيعي
واطنان الزباله الغزل اللي بيطلع منها
ومصادر تانيه كتير
غاز الميثان اللي احنا بنتكلم عنه ده له
تاثير مقارب لغاز ثاني اكسيد الكربون في
رفع درجه حراره الارض مع انه بيسبب واحد
في الميه بس من نسبه التلوث اللي في الجو
99% بيسببهم السيئتو
بس الجزء المشرق ان غاز الميثان يمكن
التحكم او السيطره على انبعاثاته وتقليلها
لان مصادره زي ما احنا قلنا ممكن السيطره
عليها بشويه قوانين ده غير ان تكلفتها اقل
بكتير ده غير ان غاز الميثان مش بيفضل مش
بيتراكم في الجو للابد زي السي اوتو بيفضل
بس لمده عشر سنين او حاجه ومع ذلك قليلين
قوي على السوشيال ميديا اللي بيكلمونا عنه
وعن دوره وبيدونا حتى امل من خلاله
خليكم فاكرين ان في خلال السبع ثمان دقائق
اللي فاتوا دول الكوره دي لسه موجوده في
حليب ام ما على الارض الكره دي لسه موجوده
جوانا
بمناسبه الكلام بقى عن السوشيال ميديا
والاعلام انا الحقيقه عندي هنا سؤال ملح
جدا سؤال في الحقيقه اساس التوك توك
السؤال ده شغل بالي كتير وانا بحضر التوك
وشغل بالي واحنا بندير مبادره التنظيف
الخاصه بنا مبادره في ايدك وهو اللي شجعني
عشان اقف على الاستيدج ده النهارده عشان
اشاركه معكم والسؤال ببساطه هو
هل ممكن تكون مبادرات دعم البيئه بتاثر
على البيئه بشكل سلبي بدون وعي منها
لان هي بتستخدم استراتيجيات بتخلي الناس
تاخد خطوات سلبيه تجاه البيئه بدل ما تاخد
خطوات ايجابيه
بالمختصر يعني هل ممكن تكون بعض مبادرات
البيئه هي جزء من مشكله
خلوني اضرب لكم مثلا عشان اوصلكم الصوره
بشكل ابسط
على الاكونت بتاع مبادرتنا مبادره في ايدك
عملنا استبيان سالنا فيه مجموعه اسئله
وشاركنا مجموعه صور
اول سلايد هنا في صوره زي ما انتم شايفين
الترقيم الصوره الاولانيه هي صوره فعل
تنظيف في اكشن تغيير قاعد بيحصل دلوقتي
احنا قاعدين بنلم مخلفات وبنحطها في كيس
فعل ايجابي صح
الصوره التانيه صوره مخلفات عادي وسالت
الناس سؤال انهي صوره من دول بتخلي عندك
احساس انك عايز تغير للافضل
النتيجه كانت عايزاكم تختبروا نفسكم كده
وانا بسال ماشي هقول وهتدوا ايه اكثر فلما
سالت السؤال ده النتيجه كانت كده
71% من الناس اختارت الصوره الاولى اللي
فيها اكشن او فعل للتغيير
تاني صوره زي ما انتم شايفين الصوره شخص
نايم على جبل مخلفات
والصوره التانيه بنت ماشيه لدعم البيئه
شايله شعار واضح جدا ان هو للبيئه انت
دلوقتي وانت قاعد حتى لو انت مش قوي بفكره
البيئه انت مدرك ان هي عامله ده عشان تدعم
البيئه صح
سالت الناس نفس السؤال برده انهي حاجه
فيهم بتخليك تتحرك نحو الافضل اعتقد ان
انتم زي كده متخيلين ان الصوره دي هتاخد
رقم اكتساحي
اوكي مفاجاه 60% بس من الناس اخترت الصوره
دي بينما 40% من الناس اخترت الصوره
التانيه
اوكي السؤال اللي بعده او الصوره اللي
بعده واحد ونص ناس كتير قوي ممكن اصلا ما
تبقاش واحد ونص دي درجه الحراره المتوقعه
ان الارض تزيدها لو ما عملناش اي حاجه
بازمه المناخ فهي ممكن لناس كتير قوي ما
تبقاش بترفيل لاي حاجه مش مش مفهماهم اي
حاجه ودي صوره اكشن التنظيف فعل التنظيف
بيحصل دلوقتي وسالنا نفس السؤال انهي صوره
من دول بتخليكم عندكوا رغبه للتغيير
النتيجه كانت
82% من الناس اختارت الصوره التانيه
اخر صوره زي ما انتم شايفين الصوره
الاولانيه صور مخلفات قدام جبل جليدي
والصوره التانيه الصوره جدا مجرده ما
فيهاش اي حاجه ما فيهاش اي فعل حتى وسالنا
نفس السؤال والنتيجه كانت انا الصراحه ما
تفاجاتش انه سته وسبعين في الميه اختاروا
ده انا اللي فاجئني ال24% في 24% من الناس
اللي شاركت الاستبيان شافت ان صوره مجرده
من اي فعل او اكشن تغيير اصلا افضل برضو
مشوار مخلفات
طب النتائج دي مش بتخليكم كده تفكروا انتم
بتحبوا تشوفوا ايه او ايه فعلا الحاجات
اللي بتخليكم تتغيروا نحو الافضل او
تغيروا عاداتكم
انا مدركه ان الاستبيان اللي احنا عملناه
ده مش ورقه بحثيه لكنه ممكن يكون بدايه
لدراسات بيئيه او حتى للمؤسسات المهتمه
بالموضوع انها تعيد تفكير اصلا في اثر
المحتوى اللي هي بتنشره على علاقتنا
بالبيئه وانه ممكن جدا يكون كل اللي
بيتعمل لدعم البيئه بيؤدي بدون قصدنا
لنتايج عكسيه
زي ان انا مثلا بسبب المحتوى ده نعتاد
القبح ونعتاد على منظر الزباله اللي في
الشارع واللي في النيل واللي على البحر
ومن كتر ما بنشوف زباله اصلا في باك
جراوند اغلب المسلسلات والافلام بقينا نحس
انه عادي زي اننا نحس بالياس القاتل وان
خلاص ان شاء الله الارض هتنتهي بالكثير
على الجمعه الجايه من كتر ما بنشوف افلام
الخيال المناخي او افلام
انا بفكر معكم وبقول جايز يكون الحل انه
مبادرات البيئه تبدا تتبنى اكتر فكره
صحافه الحلول ومن اسمها ان هي تعرض لنا
حلول اكتر وفعاليات ايجابيه اكتر ما تركز
على السلبيات الحقيقه ان كلامي ده مش مجرد
افتراضات لكن مجموعه باحثين اوروبيين
نشروا ورقه بحثيه في ازمه المناخ تحديدا
وقالوا ان الناس ممكن تاخد خطوات لما
تلاقي قصص ايجابيه بتتنشر وبتشجعها ان هي
كمان تغير اعدادها
وده بالظبط اللي ظهر من اخر سؤال سالناه
في الاستبيان لما قلنا للناس انهي صور
بيكون لها تاثير ايجابي عليك تسعه وستين
في الميه من الناس اختارت الصور اللي فيها
فعل ايجابي او اكشن للتغيير اكتر من صور
المخلفات والكائنات اللي بتتخانق في
البلاستيك ايه بقى علاقه الكوره بكل ده
الحقيقه ان الكوره دي
تصوير مكبر عن كره تانيه صغيره جدا جدا
اصغر من نقطه مرسومه بقلم على كف ايدي
الكوره دي هي الميكرو بلاستيك
والمايكرو بلاستيك وصل جسمنا عن طريق
سايكل تراكميه فضلت تحصل مع الوقت يعني
مثلا تخيل جدك في السبعينات واقف بيدخل
سيجاره على البحر ولا في باله وبعدين خلاص
خلص العلبه ورماها او طارت فبفعل الهوا
والمد والجزر البلاستيك ده او العلبه دي
وصلت البحر مع الوقت البلاستيك اللي جوه
العلبه بدا يتكسر لقطع صغيره
والقطعه دي بتبدا كل ما تتكسر كل ما تمتص
ملوثات ومواد كيميائيه من المحيط اللي
حواليها وبسبب صغر حجمها بتتشابه مع اكل
الكائنات البحريه
فطبعا الكائنات البحريه ابلع
والنتيجه حاجه من الاتنين
يا الميكروب بلاستيك بيتراكم جوه الانسجه
الهضميه والتنفسيه للكائنات دي في
الكائنات دي تموت يا بيتراكم بس قبل ما
تموت بقى احنا بنلحق نصطادها ونعمل على
حسها اكله صيد معتبر
وبكده الكوره دي بقت موجوده في دمي ودمك
وحليب الام وانسجه اغلب الكائنات اللي
عايشه على وجه الارض
عشان تتاكدوا ان حاله الام دي مش حاله
فرديه في بحث استمر لمده سبع سنين على
الطيور البحريه في منطقتنا منطقه البحر
المتوسط واثبت ان 44% من الطيور اللي
اتعمل عليها البحث جوه جسمها بلاستيك ده
غير ان في بحث تاني اتعمل في بريطانيا
اثبت ان واحد من كل ثلاث سمكات اتعمل
عليهم البحث برضو جوه جسمهم بلاستيك البحث
الاخير ده كان في 2013 يعني من عشر سنين
فما بالكم دلوقتي لا تمام دلوقتي احنا
خلاص البلاستيك بقى في حليب 26 ام من اصل
34 اتعمل عليهم بحث اخير في اكتوبر
دلوقتي زي ما قلنا الكوره دي جوانا واثر
التلوث والمناخي ما بقاش مقتصر على هل على
نهايه العالم وذوبان القطب الشمالي لا
تاثير ده جوا بقى جوانا في جسمنا على
الناحيه الجسديه والنفسيه
طيب هل كنت تتخيل في يوم ان التلوث
المناخي يبقى له تاثير على بقائنا من
ناحيه البيولوجيه بمعنى يعني هيخلينا
ننقرض اصلا قبل ما الارض تنتهي
الحقيقه في دراسه حديثه بتثبت بالارقام
نقص خصوبه الرجال في العالم في خلال
الخمسين سنه اللي فاتوا بنسبه تخض
بنسبه واحد في الميه سنويا تركيز
الحيوانات المنويه عند الرجال بينقص واحد
في الميه سنويا من بدايه البحث
والبحث بيقول انه او بيرجع الموضوع ده
للتلوث المناخي واللايف ستايل السيء اللي
بقينا عايشين به كانسان معاصر ده غير ان
في اصلا عموما يعني دراسات بتقول ان هيكون
في تاثير سلبي على خصوبه السيدات والسديات
بشكل عام
في بقى نقاشات علميه تانيه بتقول ان كل ما
زادت درجه الحراره الارض كل ما بقى عندنا
اضطرابات في النوم ده غير ان في تانيين
بيدرسه اصلا علماء تانيين بيدرسوا اثر ده
على القلق والارق والطرابات المزاج
والاكتئاب بشكل عام كل ده لسه تحت الدراسه
لكن اعتقد ان انتم ممكن تتخيلوا كده
افتكروا نفسكم كده في شهر 8 وانتم مش
طايقين نفسكم
وانتم مش قادرين تكملوا اي حاجه وانتم مش
عارفين تناموا كويس اصلا اعتقد ممكن
العلماء بداوا يدوروا في الحته دي
طيب
في 2019 كنت رايحه البحر انا واصحابي عادي
نشرب كوبايتين شاي ونروق يعني وبعدين
اتصدمنا من المنظر البحر
فقلت لهم ماذا لو قلنا يلا ننضف البحر
فكركم حد هيعبرنا فالحقيقه هم كانوا
شاطرين جدا وشجعوني وقالوا لي يلا جربي
فجربت وعملت اول ايفنت اللي في ايدك في
2019 وانا حاسه انه بنت لي انا وتلاته
اصحابي هنلم زباله ونروح بيتنا الحقيقه دي
كانت النتيجه اغلب الناس اللي في الصوره
دي ما يعرفوش اصلا اذا كان ده اذا انت
حقيقي ولا لا ما يعرفوش اصلا مين اللي
عامل الايف ما عرفوش اي حاجه هم كل اللي
هم عارفينه ان هم جايين يلموا مخلفات ناس
تانيه من على البحر وده على فكره شبه اللي
احنا بنعمله ااا في الدول الناميه احنا
كمان بنلمت ناس تانيه
الحكايه دي ممكن تحسسك ان انا نشطه هي
وكده
الحقيقه ده مش حقيقه خالص انا عملت
المبادره دي عشان انضف البحر ولا في بالي
بيئه ولا يحزنون
لكن كل ما كنت بدور كنت بتصدم من
المعلومات اللي بعرفها وكنت بحس بالاحباط
القاتل وبقول هنغير ايه يعني لا الوقود
الاحفوري هنقدر نتخلى عنه ولا بلاستيك
هنعرف نوقفه ولا هنعرف نشرع قوانين اصلا
ضد المسؤولين عن الموضوع ده وحتى احنا
يعني مدينه على سواحل منخفضه فبالتالي اي
ارتفاع في منسوب البحر احنا اول ناس
هنتقصر
مبادرتنا واكيد مبادرات كتيره بيبدو عليها
السذاجه انا عارفه ان انتم كنتوا بتفكروا
ده دلوقتي وعندكم حق اصل هنغير ايه
والطياره الخاصه لواحده من المغنيات
الشهيرات في العالم طلعت انبعاثات قد اللي
طلعوا متوسط الفرد في مصر في 2019 بثلاث
الاف مره زياده طيرتها لوحدها طلعت قدم
بعد ست الفرد ب 3000 مره
انا عارفه ان الكلام ده ممكن يبدو محبط
شويه بس هو في الحقيقه واقعي واقعنا بيقول
ان انا اقل قاره بتطلع انبعثات بنسبه اقل
من اربعه في الميه ده غير ان مصر بتطلع
اقل من واحد في الميه قصاد ثلاث دول روسيا
امريكا والصين تقريبا بيطلعوا نص انبعاثات
العالم اجمع
كلام الواقعي ده مش ضد الرغبه في التغيير
كلام الواقعي ده ضد المبالغه في الرغبه في
التغيير
طب انتم بتفكروا دلوقتي
ببساطه وبالخلاصه كده احنا دورنا مؤثر ومش
مؤثر فزوره صح
الحقيقه احنا دورنا ان احنا نعرف احنا
بنسبب قد ايه من نسبه التلوث في العالم
نعرف حجم تاثيرنا في ازمه المناخ اصلا
نفصل حلول على مقاسنا
ناخد الهامنا من محيطنا وننشر التوعيه
اللي تتناسب معنا احنا على منصاتنا ومع كل
ده ندرك ان احنا مش هنقدر ننقذ العالم
لوحدنا
احنا مش محتاجين نبطل بلاستيك
ايوه احنا مش محتاجين نبطل بلاستيك بس
احنا محتاجين نقلله
محتاجين نعيد تدوير اي حاجه من اول ادوات
المطبخ لحد الهدوم محتاجين نقفل النور
ونفتح الحنفيه على قد استخدامنا وكل
الكلام اللي اهالينا بيقوله لنا ده لكن
الفكره انه احنا كمصريين اصلا بنعمل ده
بطبيعتنا من غير ما نعرف انه اسمه حفظ
للموارد بس الفكره هنا ان احنا محتاجين
نطور ده نخلي شكل استخدامه اكثر في عقليه
محتاجين ندعم الاستدامه لان فيها حلول
حقيقيه لمشاكل كثير زي التلوث والاستهلاك
وغيره
انا عارفه ان كل دي مش حلول جديده بس
الحقيقه الحلول الجديده مش هتيجي دلوقتي
الحلول الجديده هتيجي لما نشخصن دورنا في
الازمه ونقدم افكار تناسبنا بجد بدل ما
ناخد الهامنا الاساسي والاول من دول
العالم الاول
باختصار
كافراد في دوله ناميه احنا اول ناس هتتاثر
باي توابع بائيه ومحتاجين نضغط على
السوشيال ميديا بالتوعيه والمعرفه وان
احنا نستخدم الاستراتيجيات الصح اللي مش
بتادي النتايج عكسيه عشان بدورنا ده يضغط
على المنصات العالميه وهي بدورها تضغط على
المسؤولين عشان ياخدوا خطوه
محتاجين نعرف ان اثارنا موجود وفي ايدنا
بس لازم نحوله لشكل فعال اكتر لينا
والعالم اللي حوالينا
شكرا
[تصفيق]